a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono fa vj oggi siamo sul
videogame più strano che voi possiate
mai vedere in tutta la vostra vita e
giuro che non sto scherzando
si chiama plug'n'play che devo a devo
attaccare la spina
che bello un gioco difficile wow che
allora non dovrebbe essere troppo
difficile plug and play tanto c'è musica
cori di chiesa era roba tipo di due sono
due dita o mio dio crediti è una roba
che cos'è un mio cazzo sono lunghe non è
un dito è un pene questo cos'è un
lombrico lega spiega tema da questa è
successo mi state spiegando che cosa
perché c'è un uomo che ha una presa al
posto del cerd della testa maki maki che
chi sviluppa artisti 2 va dove vai
hai un annuncio da the star ha sbattuto
sul cursore del mouse
spiegatemi come come è possibile non
possa averti sulla coscienza per averti
ucciso svegliati tocco il piru lino ti
tocco il piru lino non si sa è che si è
svegliato e vai da un parrucchiere per
cortesia cioè voglio capire io il senso
di questa cosa fa breakdance cosa devo
fare qualcosa nei commenti
esigo le spiegazioni a questa lesivo e
va a fan culo
spiegatemi a cosa sto giocando vi
supplico ma che adesso è bianco
comincerà un esercito sin dall'inizio
ragazzi sapevo che saremmo stati invasi
da dei da delle prese a si toccano ma
come el aromi oddio che triplo cosa sta
succedendo che videogioco è questa lega
ma perché ma perché non ho giocato a
carte prima
cos'è ragazzi questo è il sesso secondo
le prese almeno credo che sia così
c'è uno si collega all'altro e godono
credo di aver infatti sono sono
collegati si si sa si avvicina posso
avvicinarlo perfetta vicinati che lei
di dio santo ancora ecco basta finito
bastardo di merda è morto è my back del
culetto però è morto e ci dispiace è
proprio una sfida tutti che muoiono
quest'oggi ancora fino all'inizio ne
rimarrà soltanto lui è leggenda o
premere sul tasto si anche questo è il
sesso è una cosa che non capisco però ok
comunque k che sta roba
nelle prese ma anche a di edito lo però
che ne so posso prenderlo quel no niente
vabbè sinistra e se lo collegava a
destra cosa succedeva che è successo ma
mi pare che questo significa perdere la
testa viene a data un'altra le o
incrociate malissimo però che state
morto questo ragazzino scoreggia che la
metà bassa
no no no no ragazzi no mi sto rifiutando
di fare questa cosa ma perché ma di mark
va bè scotta nisio tele mangi tu queste
cose sono due o un pochettino di prima
grazie a si è ripagato la presa
fantastico quindi posso rimetta nella
testa vero giusto svoltasi a in atto che
non hai il pene ecco ha cambiato
discorso è non cambiare discorso non hai
pene cazzi tuoi cos'è questo lo posso
mettere a e ora c'è l'altro perfetto
bene e stato bello non è finito però ci
stiamo sperando istat e per assistere
all'amore fatto da due persone a mia mi
ha salutato ahi ahi zio e low buy
facciamolo ti conosco mi conosci ti
conosco
e sempre bello quando vedete due prese
che non lo so ma claudio io ti conosco
lo so è che dialoghi da madonna no tu
non lo sai io lo so sicuramente sì si no
[Musica]
smettiamola vi prego cosa fanno ancora
con questi dialoghi all'odio
io non penso di amarti io ti amo e
insisto penso che tu non mi ami
abbracciami non sono sicura ragazzi vi
prego bisogno di un abbraccio io ti amo
io non ti amo mi ferisce non c'era altra
scelta se non mi ferisce me ne vado ma
che a [ __ ] di merda e lui rimane voi è
triste vedere che cosa distanza dai
ragazzi non fate mai queste cose un
ragazzo potrebbe rimanerci male per il
resto della sua vita è una roba allora
questo via grazie a questo via perfetto
[Musica]
mi svegliata che cosa cazzo sto giocando
lega vi prego ok bene tutto chiaro che
una voglia di spiegarmi io vado avanti
così
ecco ci sono o che cosa bellissima
inglobate di adesso bravi a farlo ai
sono quelli di prima tu sei la [ __ ] ce
la stanno facendo legherebbe questo e
godimento poi arriva l'altro fanno altri
so ma è una roba normale ragazza
tranquilla se questa roba dovrebbe
essere tipo la rappresentazione di
quello che sto facendo con le prese
adesso il terzo che arrivato dovrebbe
infilarli nel nel camp ranzi vediamo se
è così però non entrò ragazzo di presa
ok eccolo bellizio geniale è bellissima
cos'è e degli umani centipede con la con
le prese per non vi state arrapanti no
no eh va beh va beh ecco bravo partecipa
è così dove infilare l'altra presa bene
tutta una presa per il culo poche parole
no no no è questo e quando tenti di far
l'amore per la prima volta e non sai
dove centrale il buco ma porca [ __ ]
cos'è questo ma nel kamasutra non c'è
scritta questa cosa come devo fare
colleghiamo se due tipo si può è uno che
si collega da solo o mio ok no no
no ragazzi sono cose mai viste io mi sto
rifiutando di crederci ma che cazzo
state facendo
ragazzi questo è un dopo sbornia ma
pesante poco hanno bevuto che lancia
bassa ma bravi sto facendo e cosa sta
succedendo ancora le dita ma basta
stavolta sono mani perfetto ti però è
mancato il dito zio mi dispiace non è
una cosa vi prego datemi dell'estate no
era finto era finto no no succede
no basta in cul harvey è che carica
spiro a lui ha finito ragazzo aveva
finito il godimento esce dalla porta per
niente di strano a posto clic
e la cosa più bella che io abbia mai
visto guardarlo sembra che si allunghi
il pene così devo cliccare sta cosa si
sa si ammoscia tono dritto il pene
sempre dritto plug'n'play niente lega
dovrebbe essere finito così open web
site no perché ho paura di vedere che
cosa cazzo avete messo nello sito prova
beh è un gioco super emozionante ma che
problemi hanno prodotto col mouse questi
le dita si avvicinano ma cove
qui i ragazzi era un gioco artistico
sogna essere veramente tanto in botta
per fartelo piacere spero sia piaciuto
anche voi se non avete idea di che cosa
cazzo avete appena visto io non ho idea
di che cosa cazzo di abbia appena
giocato quindi siamo a posto
se avete delle discussioni sulla vita e
sul perché le prese continuano a
prenderci per il culo
io non ho la risposta quindi ragazzi se
il video è piaciuto ma sotto sotto
quanto mi piace per ogni mi piace che
mettete ci sarà una presa in più che
verrà infilata nel culo di qualcuno
anche la pagina di facebook che
condivido con la terra sfiziose vestiti
scarpe ci mettiamo passioni di ragazze